PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka.
And in this episode,
I am pleased to have
Jen Person back with us to
talk about another mobile app
backend service solution.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good morning, Jen.
Welcome back to "Get
Cooking in Cloud."
JEN PERSON: Thanks, Priyanka.
I'm super excited to
share today's solution.
I think it's a real winner.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So last
time you were on the show,
you left us on a bit
of a cliffhanger.
You shared a mobile app
backend service solution
using Firebase and App
Engine standard environment.
My app, Priyanka's
Kitchen, uses avatars
in cloud storage for Firebase.
I need a way to create thumbnail
versions of larger images.
I'll need to be able to
download the full-size image,
scale it, download
the scaled version,
and then write back
to cloud storage.
That means I will need to
write to the file system.
But so far, you didn't recommend
the recipe for backend services
that call native binaries,
write to the file system,
or make other system calls.
I am really excited to
see that solution today.
JEN PERSON: That's
right, Priyanka.
In an earlier
episode, I explained
that Firebase solves a lot
of the mobile app backend
problems.
And last episode, we saw
that adding App Engine
standard environment
provides a backend service
to modify the synchronized
data, filling a gap
in the Firebase-only solution.
But as you pointed out, App
Engine standard environment
cannot solve every problem.
For your image
thumbnail example,
we definitely need a
different solution.
Are you ready to see it?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I am
waiting with bated breath.
Let's cook it up.
JEN PERSON: So again, here's our
recipe from the last episode.
And here's today's recipe.
That's right.
In this design
pattern, we still use
Firebase for all its mobile
app backend benefits.
But instead of App Engine
standard environment,
we use App Engine
flexible environment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I notice
that the ingredient here
is the same--
App Engine.
And this looks very similar
to last episode's recipe,
but it differs in an
important way, right?
JEN PERSON: Yes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Like App
Engine standard environment,
App Engine flexible
environment is
an app platform that
monitors, updates, and scales
the hosting environment.
All you need to do is write your
mobile backend service code.
Those features are the same.
Where App Engine standard and
flexible environment differ
is that flexible environment
runs your backend service
inside a Docker container
that you can configure.
JEN PERSON: Exactly.
And this means that you
can call native binaries,
write to the file system,
and make other system calls--
all the things you
can't do an App Engine
standard environment.
So if your app needs to process
user data or orchestrate
events, extending Firebase with
App Engine flexible environment
gives you automatic real-time
data synchronization
without needing to run your code
inside the App Engine sandbox.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
this solution is obviously
a bit more flexible.
JEN PERSON: Yep.
As the name implies, the App
Engine flexible environment
will give you more flexibility.
This is a great solution
for Firebase apps
that need a backend service to
modify the synchronized data.
And that service requires a
custom server configuration
or third-party libraries that
aren't supported by App Engine
standard environments.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Are
there any other benefits
to the flexible environment?
JEN PERSON: There is one more.
You may recall that the App
Engine standard environment
only holds a connection
open for two minutes.
Well, App Engine
flexible environment
can hold a connection
open for 24 hours.
So for example, you can
use this architecture
for backend services that
require a persistent connection
to Firebase to receive
notifications of data changes.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I can totally
see how that would be useful.
JEN PERSON: Definitely.
And since you can write
to the file system,
you can use this recipe
to generate thumbnails
for Priyanka's Kitchen.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
that's all for today
on "Get Cooking in Cloud."
Jen, thank you so much
for coming on the show.
If you would like to know
more about today's recipe,
you can check out the Firebase
and App Engine guides,
reference docs, the
code samples on GitHub
and the Firebase
YouTube channel.
JEN PERSON: And if
you like this video,
then check out the other
episodes in the series.
Don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
so you can be notified
about new episodes of "Get
Cooking in Cloud," as well
as other great Google Cloud
content.
[MUSIC FADING OUT]